all right listen to this
um remember milo yiannopoulos
milo yiannopoulos
was a brit he's still british uh milo
yiannopoulos was a guy
a gay british man former guest on this
program he won't come on anymore i've
invited him to figure out what's going
on with him won't come on anymore
mileanopolis he became a right-wing
darling
his
framing was listen i am
um a
i think he would he was gay catholic and
jewish
i don't know who knows what of this
stuff is even true
and his whole position was
the left can't go after me
as one of these
homophobic
whatever right-wingers
because i'm gay and catholic and jewish
or you know all the different things
he then um
was i want to be careful with the
language
he then was uh on video
sort of defending i'm not going to use
some of the words that were used to
describe it because i don't think it was
accurate he was on video
defending
sexual contact
between adults and
what are legally
children
um
and that kind of torpedoed his career
and he disappeared for a while
and then more recently he has kind of
attempted to rehabilitate himself by
saying i am now heterosexual he says
he's no longer gay
and um
yeah make of that what you will and he's
also now i guess i guess a much more
devout catholic that's another part of
it so he's been appearing on like real
america's voice i think and all these
different right-wing places and it just
he's like not really getting traction
so a viewer says david milo is now
selling
um
statuettes of the virgin mary
on on like a christian version of the
home shopping network and i said guys
this can't possibly be true it's got to
be some kind of satire it's not
it's not milo yiannopoulos is now
selling virgin mary statues
and other religious paraphernalia on
something called church militant store
just look at this hello and welcome to
the church militant shop my name is milo
younopolis and i'm here with my co-host
deborah vaughan how are you doing today
debra i'm doing okay how are you i'm
well i'm happy because this is the first
of our shows and we're beginning today
with
well probably the most important woman
in history wouldn't you say i think so
she's certainly the most beloved and
we've got today uh three
items all in celebration reverence of
course of the blessed mother extremely
uh powerful religious items here the
virgin mary we're going to start with um
this wonderful statue which we both own
we do but in different uh medium oh
different colors that's right you've got
the silver finish yes and i've got this
bronze finish so for the low low price
of 87.50 you can get the adoring virgin
statue with made from cold cast poly
resin in either bronze or silver
perfect for some kind of strange
basement altar or just keeping on your
bedside table if you're ever having
trouble sleeping and need to look at
something that will calm you down order
now
tell us a little bit about the material
this is made from because it's a little
bit special and it looks like a it's
going to weigh a ton and cost 100 to
ship and i want to make sure i have it
right so it's it's a um
cold cast and it's hand painted bronze
color or you can get it in the pewter
sometimes
one or the other might be on back order
but they come in
um
it's very popular
right um
it i have a shrine at home is this funny
or is it depressing guys is it is it
just depressing that this is what milo
is now doing i have mine in in my shrine
and it looks very very nice
um well i was joking about putting it in
an altar but the woman's literally
saying i have a shrine at home and it
you know it's called the adoring virgin
and i adore her i actually have a rosary
hanging from her i do the same thing do
you do the same thing
one of the nice things about
this particular statue yeah
is the shroud
and on your silver version um something
shows up on the back a little bit more
than on this one this is more of a sort
of uh like a a an age metal finish on
the silver one you get a little bit more
of the detail popping out i think but
i'm just going to that's a contrast of
color right i'm going to turn this
around and maybe you could explain to us
a little bit about the shroud so the
shroud is oh my god so then they get
into a different i want to find this
other moment they start talking about i
guess now they move into selling a bible
this is a year with mary daily
meditations on the mother of god this is
a very special bible milo has now put
his glasses on for this because it's
very very serious or blind because they
think well you know just i'm just not
sure what i'm going to get out of it
because some of it you know there's a
lot of historical names
this is um selected to be
endlessly fascinating you know every day
it's a completely different tone and
style and author there's a lot of
swimsuits in alphonsus ligouri but
there's also you know uh louis de
montfort pope benedict the 16th all
kinds of different meditations and
thoughts on mary
so i thought i'd read one from a fellow
brit uh the blessed john henry newman so
milo will now read a meditation on the
virgin mary from a bible you can buy for
45 bucks
british writing always sounds better i
always love to hear you read well thanks
um so i'll just read you this is day 155
so that they're the good thing about is
they're numbered so you can start it at
any time right you don't have to wait
until january to start your year with
her you can just you can keep track
yourself thank god right i mean imagine
having to wait until january to start
the readings we just use a pencil to
check them off or something um so it's
called mary vessel of devotion and in
this the blessed john henry newman
illustrates the meaning of devotion and
shows how our lady overflowed with
devotion to her son
to be devout okay and i'm gonna stop it
there because i i'm trying to i'm not
trying to prevent a cringe stream today
um this is surreal guys this this is
completely and totally surreal and if
you go to the church militant shop you
can get everything from catholic mugs
to um
package deals including prayer books and
various different elements
you can get a catholic me too t-shirt
you can also buy metals even in art deco
style guys what the hell is going on in
this country
or any country for that matter milo
isn't you know he's british let me know
whether this is sad
funny
or something in between